Tirico trialing and it easy pops back
it's a long shot but you're gonna close
out on him a bloody only that in the D
chains Conrad Fitch doing it as well the
three-point shot has a chance for the
four-point play Wildcats with the
momentum Illawarra still with the lane
the handoff fits better on red it's a
much needed basket full of Milan feeds
it to AJ who oesn't one nice and
delivers that's exactly how you pay your
point I've been labelled a ball eighteen
year old with all the hype takes it
himself this time
and shows us a little trick or turn a
hundred Xena grooves what you say on
this particular occasion who knows
what's going to looks big we're out of
the force from if big crowd at the
winning entertainment center cool steps
back for three
I'm from the 18-year old and that is the
biggest part of the game they just gotta
capitalize on the other end ball to look
him in the eye steps in gave it up
rolling do i smooth blow the hands it up
Brooks back to Anderson and uses all
that experience to sensational third
from him lamellae ball 26 seconds to
play with two Anderson's from outside
Big Dave Melo rips down the rebound and
rips it down the floor
spins moves gives greeter corner use
versus experience danger time right now
for the Hawks
the Melo from way outside what were you
doing when you alright ten years of a to
use on the shot clock
five left gives it back out Paul Conrad
one left Japan in the blink of an eye
they're back in it bring it down the
floor outstripped hand back inside
takes it to the with four seconds left
three-point game